hello everyone my name is dr. Miller the
SCP were going to be studying today is
SCP 28:52 object class Keter special
containment procedures containment of
SCP 28 52 is to focus on tracking and
disruption of incidents where possible
and general monitoring of SCP 2852
compatible population centers all
individuals involved in blue level and
white level events are to be monitored
extensively and their identities are to
be given to local law enforcement as
potential terrorist threats even when
disrupted individuals involved in blue
level and white level events are to be
catalogued and their names are to be
sent to local law enforcement agencies
individuals witnessing the disruption of
either event are to be given Class B
amnestics
black level events are to be monitored
until conclusion afterwards all
participants are to be treated with
Class A amnestics and/or otherwise
treated identically to those affected by
other events members of mobile task
forces epsilon 36 epsilon 52 and epsilon
99 who witness a black level event are
to be treated with Class A amnestics
upon retirement or transfer and are to
be monitored for any signs of antisocial
or otherwise uncharacteristic behavior
if found to have been infected by the
black level event operatives are to be
at Nesta sized suspended from all field
operations and re designated to low
level low intensity work a maintenance
data input mobile task force y 36 party
crashers are tasked with responding to
any SCP 28:52 appearance bubble task
forces y 52 gator duty and y 99 altar
boys are tasked to identify 2852 events
and provide backup to mobile task force
y 36 as needed bubble task forces y 52
and y 99 are to establish presence
within communities where 60% of the
population is Roman Catholic or as of
revision 28:52 7 Anglican any SCP 2852
instance found attached to a different
religious group must be reported to a
researcher with level 4 28:52 clearance
immediately while currently isolated to
the north american subcontinent all SCP
28:52 compatible communities are to be
monitored for an uncharacteristic rise
in juvenile delinquency sterility
domestic violence and divorce rates
description instances of scp-2059
[Music]
stencil are genetically identical and
human
however instances do not have any
identifiable organs their bodies are
made up of fibrous muscular tissue with
the teeth and hair being made out of
tighten chemically similar to those of
the sick of dead a family the eyes of
SCP 28:52 instances while looking
non-anomalous from a distance are set in
the sockets without any nerve connection
while capable of speech despite having
no vocal cords or analog s organs SCP
28:52 instances do not show any grasp of
language speaking in a word salad
despite this all individuals at an SCP
28:52 compatible event will perceive the
subject as speaking intelligibly and
will regard its actions as normal unless
briefed of its anomalous properties
beforehand individuals describe a CP
28:52 as being playful with a crude
sense of humor and all individuals
affected in an SCP 2852 event will refer
to the subject as cousin Johnny while
sentient SCP 2852 instances do not
appear sapient SCP 28:52 instances
appear at various Catholic and Anglican
religious functions and are treated as
being an established member of the
family
instances of scp-2059 s-- or ethnicity
the entity appears at baptisms weddings
and funerals referred to as blue level
white level and black level events
respectively
currently no SCP 2852 instance has been
found to appear at any other family
gathering all attempts at tracking SCP
2852 instances before and after an event
have met with failure the entities are
able to appear at such events as though
they
always been there alternatively
appearing between frames when under
surveillance or simply evading any
attempt to buy operatives to keep them
out of an event all tracking devices
placed on SCP 2852 instances have
malfunctioned immediately with the
entity evading any surveillance each
family gathering that SCP 2852 attends
result in a different behavior from the
subject and different effects generally
the effects of SCP 2852 appearing in a
family gathering result in more serious
damage done to children although adults
are not free of its effects it is worth
noting that stopping an SCP 2852
instance before it involves itself in
their religious ritual will not stop its
effects from spreading although they may
be diluted the appearance of SCP 28:52
at an event is enough for its effects to
start spreading among the family when
questioned after an event all affected
individuals report a feeling of fondness
towards SCP 2852 regardless of its
actions during an event i will now cover
the blue white and black level events
starting with the blue SCP 2852 s
effects at a blue level event are
present more strongly in the child being
baptized its parents and any godparents
chosen for the occasion during the
baptismal ritual SCP 28:52 will involve
itself directly in the proceedings
acting as a third godparent when
traditionally there are only two a male
and a female blue level events proceed
identically despite the presence of a
third godparent until the child is
submerged into the water immediately
the child's top layer of skin will
slough off in one piece is though molten
this process does not seem to harm the
child in any meaningful way the
godparents will then eat the skin
between each other afterwards the mass
will go on as normal an SCP 2852 will
exit along with the family
it is of note that SCP 28:52 does not
appear at any family celebration held
after the baptism the baptized child has
a chance of dying within the next 6
months well above the national average
living children exhibit multiple cluster
B personality disorders most join
anti-capitalist groups various groups of
interest or if unchecked will engage in
destructive behavior usually manifesting
in self-harm abusive animals or abusive
small children godparents and biological
parents will be rendered sterile
regardless of SCP 2852 success in
becoming part of the baptismal ritual
both groups commit suicide within 5
years of a blue level event normally
through drowning all individuals not
involved in the baptismal ritual are
500% more likely than the national
average
to have still births those who are still
capable of having children are far more
likely to abandon them sometimes
allowing the child to die in the process
one couple affected by a blue level
event in Ohio gave birth to triplets
which they then tore apart and hung from
trees are on their property past
adolescence into adulthood children
exposed to the song of cicadas respond
with extreme anxiety and accompanying
physical symptoms such as dry mouth
nausea vomiting diarrhea and headaches
some subjects agitation escalates into
violent outbursts which have resulted in
at least 20 fatalities when interviewed
about the cause of their disturbance no
subjects have ever identified cicada
song as a trigger for their episodes
even in one interview involving a level
5 enhanced interrogation the subject
never indicated the role of a cicada
song in his attack on the parish which
resulted in 18 dead 10 wounded including
his parents and three siblings
next white level event
during the marriage ceremony SCP 2852
will insert itself as a groomsman and
its most deleterious anomalous effect
will only manifest after the vows after
the Rings have been exchanged SCP 28:52
will produce various implements that
allow the bridesmaids and groomsmen to
pull out their teeth one by one the
individuals seem to be oblivious to any
pain that would normally take place
during such an event and blood loss
through still unknown means does not
occur the bride and groom will be
presented with the teeth and will eat
them damage done to the bride and the
groom's teeth and jaw are extensive but
any blood loss that occurs will not be
fatal
the groom will then in place of vows
vocalize a currently unknown cicada song
which has been known to reach a hundred
and forty decibels
rendering the bride and those on the
altar deaf currently no groom has been
deafened by his own call at the wedding
reception SCP 28:52 will take the role
of the best man and give a speech as all
vocalizations of SCP 2852 will be
nonsensical with no pattern to the words
used individuals will react to the
speech with mixed emotions some crying
uncontrollably and others falling into
hysterical laughter after the speech SCP
2850 tool produce a gift for the married
couple
this gift currently has always been 3.5
kilograms of human hair various colors
13 to see specimen of to bison Lynn eye
and 23 human teeth in a cardboard box
DNA testing on all gifts have been
inconclusive
the bride and groom of a white level
event will divorce on average two years
after their wedding usually as a result
of domestic violence any children
produced during their marriage will have
cluster B personality disorders or
life-threatening disfigurements all
married individuals attending the event
will find themselves unable to have
children despite a lack of detectable
Changez to fertility related biology
sperm counts and sperm quality remain
unaffected ovulation also remains
unchanged and no genetic irregularities
have been observed in eggs the
foundation has arranged a statistically
significant number of hysterectomies for
guests at white level events the
surgeries are prescribed and
administered by third-party agents in
the medical industry exhaustive biopsies
chemical analysis and mechanical
inspections of the extract at uteri and
ovaries have failed to yield any signs
of abnormality all children involved in
a white level event will avoid romantic
relationships a nine out of ten commits
suicide by the age of 18
roughly half pull out their teeth until
blood completely blocks the airways and
others bite their own wrists until
exsanguinated and finally a black level
event black level events are notable and
that any attempt to disrupt the event
through any means result in the actor
becoming a participant in the event
currently there exists no way to stop or
end a black level event any attempts at
barring a-c-p 2852 instances from the
church or funeral home result in SCP
2852 simply appearing in a pew during a
black level event SCP 2852 will take the
place of the eulogize ER even if one was
not scheduled to speak during the mass
the speech as any vocalization by a CPE
2852 will be nonsensical with no
patterns being found however as the
subject speaks the individual closest to
the departed will open the casket and
produce a long knife the knives produced
during a black level event are not seen
before the event and disappear after the
event the individual will then
exsanguinate themselves normally from
the wrists but there have been instances
where individuals have slit their
throats in turn to buy to each attendant
will use the knife to pour their blood
into the casket
children too young to exsanguinate
themselves are helped by adults despite
many losing enough blood to result in
death no physical effects are seen in
participants SCP 28:52 speech eventually
turns into the song an adult male to
bison Lanai all participants will
respond with the same call
despite the song of the cicada being
limited to the male SCP 2852 will stand
at the pulpit until each individual has
bled themselves and then will walk to
the casket and vomit the mixture of
blood wood pulp and dead specimen of to
bison Lanai it is currently unknown how
a CP 2852 instances are able to hold the
mixture within themselves due to the
lack of any cavity of sufficient size in
its body once finished the funeral Mass
will go on as normal and the casket
filled with blood and SCP 28:52 s vomit
will be taken to the cemetery and
lowered into the earth as is normal for
a Catholic or Anglican funeral service
black level events normally will end
here if a family gathering was planned
to take place after the funeral SCP 2852
will attend SCP 28:52 will once all
individuals affected have come to the
location vomit a similar mixture of
blood wood pulp and dead - bison Lenni
into a bowl this mixture will be
primarily eaten by the affected children
after this has been eaten SCP 2852 will
give another speech of nonsensical words
without patterns strip itself and lay on
the table the participants then will eat
SCP 2852 s flesh until there is nothing
left
during this SCP 28:52 will still
vocalize even when suffering mortal
injuries participants have been known to
carry on a friendly conversation with a
Seabee 28:52 while eating it children
unable to chew whole food proper
we'll be fed mouth-to-mouth by any
caregivers all participants of a black
level event will break from their family
either through suicide moving or divorce
every individual involved in an event
will be rendered sterile domestic
violence and participants of black level
offense will usually be of a
cannibalistic nature resulting in the
death of one or both individuals six out
of ten children involved will attempt to
murder one or both of their parents
before they turn 18 it is theorized that
nearly a third of Catholic and Anglican
d-class were involved in a black level
event or further research regarding
related phenomena please see the
database entry for SCP 3004 and that's
for another day but this is where the
lecture ends today thank you for
listening if indeed you still are and
you are all dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Desmond Hoskins
Dustin Koski Alan Setzer premier Romanov
Tibor ball and dr. mortis thank you all
so much for your support is greatly
appreciated if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos on some other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volcan thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]